parlamentswahl in israel
kopf-an-kopf-rennen zwischen amtsinhaber
netanyahu und herausforderer ganz lag
bei patientendaten millionen befunde und
röntgenbilder waren offen im netz
zugänglich und mitarbeiter dringend
gesucht für ein besseres klima sollen
mehr busse und bahnen fahren doch schon
jetzt fielen arbeitskräfte
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
einen schönen guten abend wünsche ich
ihnen willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem dienstag
norbert lehmann ist auch dabei für den
sport beim schwimmen von mir zum zweiten
mal in diesem jahr sind 6,4 millionen
israelis zur wahl aufgerufen und die
große frage ist ob es langzeit
ministerpräsident benjamin netanjahu
noch einmal schaffen kann
im april war er daran gescheitert eine
regierung zu bilden jetzt will er es
nochmal versuchen trotz einer drohenden
anklage wegen korruption
sein größter rivale ex generalstabschef
benny gantz der gibt sich in sozialen
fragen liberale ansonsten ist sein kurs
dem von netanyahu aber gar nicht so
unähnlich
aus tel aviv lippert um die stimmen der
siedler im israelisch besetzten
westjordanland hatte regierungschef
netanjahu im wahlkampf besonders stark
geworben
er kündigte selbst an bei einem wahlsieg
das jordantal zu annektieren das kommt
hier gut an
wir wollen eine regierung die unsere
siedlungen garantiert ich meine das ist
unser land egal wie man das betrachtet
seit zehn jahren regiert netanjahu das
land er gibt sich als garant für die
sicherheit israels doch seien zunehmend
aggressiver kurs gegen medien die
arabische minderheit und politische
gegner spaltet das land ist gut für die
sicherheit für die wirtschaft einfach
gut für die politik es ist höchste zeit
dass netanjahu geht das ist keine
normale situation mehr hat jede
politische vernunft verloren
ein thema im wahlkampf die konzessionen
netanjahu sun ultra religiöse
koalitionspartner die eine strengere
einhaltung religiöser vorschriften
fordern
während dringende soziale probleme wie
armut und unbezahlbare mieten unbeachtet
blieben kritisieren regierungsgegner die
religiösen erpressen uns und netanyahu
zahlt ihnen jede summe nur um an der
macht zu bleiben
während junge leute nicht einmal eine
chance haben sich eine wohnung zu kaufen
das ist das dringendste problem in
diesem land
the city auch viele arabische wähler
lehnen die als repressiv empfundene
politik netanjahus ab wir werden täglich
diskriminiert in diesem staat fühlen wir
uns wie bürger zweiter klasse
[Musik]
die hoffnungen der opposition ruhen auf
benny gantz ex-general führer des mitte
rechts bündnisses blau-weiß umfragen
sagen ein kopf-an-kopf-rennen mit
netanyahu voraus erste hochrechnungen
werden am späten abend erwartet
also kopf-an-kopf-rennen nicola albrecht
in tel aviv was würde sich denn ändern
wenn herausforderer benny gantz gewinnt
zunächst einmal würde ich mit anja und
seine ultra rechten und ultra-religiösen
koalitionspartner noch nicht abschreiben
denn in israel hat schon oft gegolten
auf netanjahus schimpfen und ihnen dann
doch wählen sollte allerdings
tatsächlich benny gantz der konkurrenz
an die macht kommen mit seinem
liberal-konservativen bündnis dann
dürfen wir auch nicht überrascht sein
wenn sie sich im kern politisch in
israel nicht so viel ändern wird
vermutlich werden die religiösen etwas
an einfluss verlieren aber es geht vor
allem um politik stil wenn ihr ganz hat
sich ganz klar als gegenentwurf zu
netanjahu inszeniert als saubermann
nicht korrumpierbar als derjenige der
die demokratischen grundwerte vertritt
allerdings hat der ehemalige militärchef
gesagt in sicherheitsfragen werde er
sogar noch härter durchgreifen
als netanjahu und auch im konflikt mit
den palästinensern dürfen wir keine
große veränderungen erwarten es wird
nicht benny gantz sein der auf sie
zugehen wird und friedensverhandlungen
initiiert diese wahl ist wirklich eine
schicksalswahl für netanjahu aber egal
wie sie ausgeht einen radikalen wandel
wird dadurch das land nicht erleben
vielen dank für diese einschätzung
nicola albrecht wenn um 21 uhr deutscher
zeit die wahllokale schließen wird es
auch erste prognosen geben die finden
sie bei uns online unter heute.de erste
ergebnisse gibt es vermutlich
mittwochmorgen
wieder eine riesige schwachstelle im
internet diesmal geht es um sensible
patientendaten röntgenaufnahmen mrt oder
ct
sicherheitsexperten haben jetzt
aufgedeckt dass sie quasi offen
zugänglich waren weltweit und
millionenfach auch in deutschland und so
kam es dazu einmal gemacht müssen die
bilder der patienten ja archiviert
werden auf speziellen server die hatten
aber weder verschlüsselung noch
passwortschutz
anders gesagt wer die ip-adresse des
archivsystems kannte war im handumdrehen
drin
brigitte sagen er hat das problem
aufgedeckt der geschah der experte für
informationssicherheit fiel auf wie
leicht der zugriff zum beispiel auf
mammographie bilder ist dabei sind
solche daten hochsensibel würden
informationen über mögliche krankheiten
öffentlich könnte dass wir patienten
auswirkungen haben beim abschluss von
krediten und versicherungen etwa oder
bei der jobsuche können sie benutzten
für erpressungsversuche ich kann die
einzelnen systeme verschlüsseln und den
betreibern erpressen
da ist viel geld im spiel
nach recherchen des bayerischen
rundfunks waren bundesweit rund 13.000
medizinische datensätze vorübergehend
abrufbar
in einer praxis in ingolstadt betraf die
sicherheitslücke über 7000 patienten
eine weitere spur führt nach kempen in
nordrhein westfalen die reporter fanden
zusätzlich ungesicherte server mit
millionen patientendaten in den usa der
türkei indien und südafrika
nach dem ersten eindruck ist noch nicht
mal die grundlegendste technische schutz
der daten erfolgen und ein teil der
datenschutzvorschriften ist auch dass
man alle technischen und
organisatorischen maßnahmen ergreift in
deutschland sind wohl hauptsächlich
arztpraxen betroffen in großen kliniken
ist eigentlich längst vorgeschrieben
patienten daten zu verschlüsseln
trotzdem gab es auch bei einer
bayerischen uni klinik vorübergehend ein
datenleck
ich kann nur alle aufrufen noch mal bei
sich zu überprüfen auch in den praxen in
den häusern
bei den dienstleistern die man hat ob
die standards eingehalten dass bisher
kein fall bekannt wurde in dem die
betroffenen daten tatsächlich
missbraucht wurden kann dabei nur
bedingt beruhigen
soll die bundesregierung nach den
angriffen auf öl raffinerien in saudi
arabien wieder waffen in das land
liefern
ein klares nein kommt von der
bundeskanzlerin sie sieht im augenblick
keinen anlass das verbot wieder
aufzuheben
us präsident hatte den iran
verantwortlich gemacht für die
bombardierungen offiziell bekannt hatten
sich die houthi rebellen im jemen
us-außenminister pompeo wird noch heute
nach saudi arabien reisen um mit der
führung dort eine mögliche reaktion auf
die angriffe zu besprechen
mittendrin im pulverfass naher osten ist
jordanien dessen könig heute bei der
kanzlerin zu besuch war
sein land ist umgeben von saudi arabien
dem irak syrien israel und den
palästinensergebieten
jordanien hat hunderttausende syrische
flüchtlinge aufgenommen und gilt als
vermittler zwischen den streitenden
ländern ganz wichtig heute für könig
abdullah den zweiten dass die bundeswehr
sich weiter am internationalen einsatz
gegen die terror miliz es beteiligt
aus berlin berichtet conny erschienen es
ist einer der angenehmeren termine der
kanzlerin der gast aus jordanien könig
abdullah findet nur lobende worte wir
sind dankbar für die
sicherheitspolitische rolle deutschlands
in unsere region und die kanzlerin
verspricht in vielen fragen der
sicherheit zylinder region weiter
miteinander eng zusammenarbeiten
das gilt insbesondere für die bundeswehr
denn deren anti es kam vom jordanischen
stützpunkt als rack aus soll nun doch
verlängert werden so wird es das
kabinett morgen beschließen terroristen
verstecken sich dann müssen sie
aufgespürt werden können damit man sie
bekämpfen kann damit man dafür sorgen
kann dass sicherheit ein zieht das kann
nur die bundeswehr
mit ihrem tornados ist die bundeswehr
vor allem für die luftaufklärung
zuständig liefert so wichtige bilder im
kampf gegen den as die spd hatte sich
lange gegen eine verlängerung des
mandats gesträubt nun das einlenken die
bisherige verteidigungsminister in von
der leyen hat es versäumt rechtzeitig
für eine ablösung zu sorgen
deshalb gewähren wir jetzt nochmal eine
frist von fünf monaten denn wir wollen
ja dass weiterhin aus der luft
aufgeklärt werden kann
aber jetzt ist es zeit dass auch andere
partner mal diese aufgabe übernehmen für
die bis zu 700 soldaten und soldatinnen
vor ort gibt es nun planungssicherheit
auch wenn der bundestag der
mandatsverlängerung noch zustimmen muss
in afghanistan sind bei zwei
bombenanschlägen fast 50 menschen ums
leben gekommen ein sprengsatz
explodierte in der nähe einer
wahlkampfveranstaltung von präsident
geri dort sterben 26 menschen
der präsident wurde nicht verletzt bei
einem bombenanschlag in kabul wurden
mindestens 22 menschen getötet
die radikal-islamischen taliban
bekannten sich zu beiden taten nach
großbritannien es ist ein in der
britischen rechtsgeschichte
beispielloser prozess der heute begonnen
hat mitten in den exit turbulenzen hatte
premierminister boris johnson das
parlament fünf wochen im zwangsurlaub
geschickt jetzt ist der supreme court
gefragt das oberste gericht erklärte
sich für zuständig muss entscheiden ob
der premier gegen verfassungsprinzipien
verstoßen hat andreas stamm berichtet
das oberste gericht die letzte instanz
eine grundsatzfrage hat premier johnson
gegen das gesetz verstoßen indem er das
parlament in die zwangspause schickt
mitten in der praxis krise davor die
demonstranten beider lager gespalten wie
die justiz zwei gerichte hatten
geurteilt 1 4 1 gegen die regierung nun
hören die obersten richter die argumente
dieser hokuspokus dass das parlament die
regierung nicht mehr zur rechenschaft
ziehen könnte was für ein unsinn
eigentlich sind es nur vier oder fünf
sitzungstage weniger als geplant
entscheidende zeit in einer staatskrise
so die opposition als das parlament vor
acht tagen in die zwangspause geschickt
wird kommt es zum eklat
[Applaus]
[Musik]
schande schreien oppositionsabgeordnete
verteidigt unsere demokratie
mitten im rexit chaos meldet sich ex
premier cameron zurück er bereue vieles
was das eu-referendum angehe
doch nicht seine entscheidung ist
abzuhalten und warnt vor nachfolger
johnson als einem prinzipien losen
populist cottbus wollte nie aus der eu
sondern nur die chance nutzen auf der
romantischen patriotischen
nationalistischen seite zu stehen um die
karriere zu befördern doch als premier
könnten die geister die johnson rief
auch sein politisches ende besiegeln
ein abkommen mit der eu ist nicht in
sicht er hat die mehrheit des parlaments
gegen sich und am ende der woche
möglicherweise auch das oberste gericht
noch eine meldung aus der wirtschaft die
beiden stromriesen eon und rwe dürfen in
wichtigen bereichen zusammenarbeiten das
hat die eu unter auflagen genehmigt
durch den tausch einiger geschäftsfelder
wird rwe künftig vor allem zum
produzenten und großhändler von strom
dann ohne eigene kraftwerke will sich
auf den transport und verkauf von strom
und gas konzentrieren
brüssel ist sicher das führe nicht zu
weniger auswahl und höheren preisen
die menschenrechtsorganisation amnesty
international hat die 16-jährige kreter
thunberg ausgezeichnet zusammen mit
ihrer klimaschutz bewegung fridays for
future der preis botschafter des
gewissens gelte den millionen
jugendlichen die seit dem vergangenen
jahr an den weltweiten schüler
demonstrationen teilnehmen sagte
thunberg in ihrer dankesrede gut fürs
klima wäre wenn mehr menschen mit bus
und bahn statt mit dem auto fahren
würden
das weiß auch die bundesregierung und
will vor allem den schienenverkehr
attraktiver machen unter anderem mit
günstigeren tickets der plan bis 2030
sollen doppelt so viele menschen den
öffentlichen fernverkehr nutzen wie
bisher
das geht aber nur mit ausreichend
personal und das fehlt schon jetzt hans
jürgen thiel berichtet
busfahrer und lokführer verzweifelt
gesucht schon jetzt kann es monate
dauern freiwerdende stellen wieder zu
besetzen wenn er künftig das
verkehrsangebot noch ausgebaut werden
soll könnte der personalmangel zum
bremsklotz der verkehrswende werden
es gibt jetzt schon personal not dass es
richtig ist fallen einzelne verkehre aus
heute schon weil personal nicht in
ausreichender menge vorhanden ist akut
sind 6000 stellen die offen sind
in zukunft wird das meer werden je mehr
der verkehr wächst weil in den nächsten
jahren besonders viele mitarbeiter in
rente gehen müssen bis 2030 im
nahverkehr 74.000 stellen wiederbesetzt
werden
der größte teil davon im fahrdienst aber
auch 20.000 in der technik und 14.000 im
kaufmännischen bereich bei einem
erweiterten verkehrsangebote wie
klimapolitisch gefordert könnten es aber
schon in fünf jahren 50.000 offene
stellen sein warnt der verkehrsverband
dringend gesucht busfahrer und vor allem
lokführer allein die deutsche bahn
braucht bis ende des jahres 2000 überall
in deutschland
doch gerade jobs im nahverkehr zählen
nicht zu den attraktivsten kritisieren
arbeitnehmervertreter lange arbeitszeit
wenig flexibilität bei den fahrern
fahrerinnen zumindestens mal was ihre
wünsche angeht und aber viel zu wenig
geld für diese verantwortungsvolle
aufgabe mit einer ersten bundesweiten
online stellenbörse wollen die
verkehrsunternehmen jetzt gegensteuern
aktuell freie stellen mehr als 5300 der
klimawandel ist schwerpunkt im zdf
programm heute abend frontal 21
beschäftigt sich mit den folgen für
deutschland und direkt davor um 20 uhr
15 zeigt harald lesch im zdf zeit die
fakten und fasst den weltweiten stand
der klimaforschung zusammen
damit sind wir im fußball champions
league heute abend warum man heute abend
vize meister dortmund durch morgen
meister in münchen genau und der bvb hat
er gleich mit dem fc barcelona eine echt
harte nuss zu knacken
leichter dürfte es da die bayern haben
gegen roter stern belgrad die münchner
sind ganz klarer favorit und wollen ganz
klar den
sechzehnten auftakt sieg in serie in der
champions league besser im griff haben
als im letzten jahr wollen die bayern
die champions league in dieser saison
die ziele klar ein neues jahr neues
spiel neues glück wir wollen auf jeden
fall erst einmal die gruppenphase
überstehen das ist unser ziel das kann
auch gar nicht groß diskutieren aber als
zweiter bin ich mir sicher bin davon
überzeugt dass wir dieses weiterkommen
werden als im letzten jahr gegen belgrad
wieder gefordert sind tore von ihm
robert lewandowski der unersetzliche ist
im moment der torgarant des deutschen
meisters schritt für schritt richtung
henkelpott der nationaltorhüter von
champions league start überzeugt
wir wissen dass wir qualität in unserem
kader haben und dass wir sehr hungrig
sind viele junge spieler auch haben und
die diesen hängt natürlich unbedingt
gewinnen wollen bzw auch die älteren die
ihn schon gewonnen haben wollen ihnen
wiederholen
bleibt zu hoffen dass trainer kubot auch
nach dem spiel morgen noch so gut
gelaunt ist wie beim abschlusstraining
heute macht geld den fußball kaputt über
diese brisante frage können sie heute
abend ab 20.15 mit zdf reporter béla
réthy diskutieren in dortmund vor dem
spiel gegen barcelona im heute plus live
stream auf heute.de der fc st pauli hat
dem hamburger sv die erste
saisonniederlage beigebracht der
kiezklub setzte sich im zweitliga derby
mit 2 zu 0 durch der erste erfolg der
paulianer gegen den stadt-rivalen am
heimischen millerntor seit 1960 eduard
popp hat bei den weltmeisterschaften in
kasachstan die dritte bronzemedaille für
den deutschen ringer-bund verpasst
der 28 jährige im schwarzen dress verlor
im kleinen finale der gewichtsklasse bis
130 kilogramm gegen den georgier jacobi
kanada klar mit 0 5 hatte sich aber
schon gestern mit dem einzug ins
halbfinale das ticket für die
olympischen spiele im kommenden jahr in
tokyo gesichert und das ist ja auch was
dabei immer noch fasziniert von diesen
männern bekommen zu viele fett bielefeld
gibt es gar nicht dass hatte mal ein
witzbold vor 25 jahren behauptet seitdem
werden die ostwestfalen
hunderttausendfach verspottet heute
haben sie in bielefeld die verschwörung
ganz offiziell begraben in der altstadt
mit gedenkstein bürgermeister und
augenzwinkern sogar eine million euro
belohnung ausgesetzt aber keiner konnte
beweisen dass bielefeld nicht existiert
also schluss mit lustig in ostwestfalen
die sonne scheint dort auch morgen im
süden viel sonne im norden auf wolken
die details hat gleich christa schepp
marietta slomka begrüßt sie um viertel
vor zehn im heute journal
und wir wünschen ihnen jetzt noch einen
schönen abend bedanken uns für ihr
interesse und sind morgen wieder darf in
sie mögen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
hier kommt der erste kleinere
herbststurm hat ja schon heute an den
küsten für eine aufgewühlte see gesorgt
aber dieses kleine sturmtief zieht jetzt
nach osten ab dafür macht sich aus
westen hoch haneke breit aber in der
nacht ist es im norden erst mal noch
windig starke bis stürmische böen sind
auf den inseln weiter möglich allerdings
lassen die schauer im norden deutlich
nach paar tropfen fällen fallen noch an
den alpen sonst sorgt das hoch schon für
auflockerungen vor allem in der mitte
und dadurch kann es morgen früh richtig
kühl seien drei bis sieben grad teils
nur nur ganz im süden und an den küsten
bleibt es bei 8 bis 12 grad
auch der tag morgen ist relativ kühl
höchstwerte meist nur zwischen 13 und 17
grad am rhein gibt es auch mal ein 18
bis 20 grad
insgesamt ist es aber relativ freundlich
morgen vor allem im süden schon viel
sonne im norden ist das noch ein sonne
wolken mix also sie können die wolken
auch noch mal dichter sein
und weil wir da immer noch diesen
frischen nordwestlichen wind haben der
die kühlere luft über die nord und über
die ostsee zu uns bringt gibt es direkt
an den küsten auch noch ein paar
regenschauer aber das war es dann auch
schon mit dem regen für die nächsten
tage die seen wieder sehr trocken aus im
süden sonnig im norden ein paar mehr
wolken zum wochenende setzt sich dann
aber überall der blaue himmel durch gut
dass wir wärmer mit bis 24 grad